hello and welcome to this video playing
22 from Denmark cat yeah this line I
should probably study this a bit more if
I if I intend to play with white move
more before if this is my line against
her um against the Kuro this is not
considered to be great for black this
line but it's it's complicated and i
recently had it on the board against the
awkward getting them yeah nothing much
and they haven't looked it up yet so I'm
inventing the wheel yet again in this
game at least I played reasonably
quickly probably something to Queen
night f4 isn't night f form basically
forcing 97 yeah makes this difficult
makes his development a little bit
difficult unless he has this miracle
move why does they look
taketake night takes I don't quite see
it only we get some development anyway
just the kind of okay place this but but
here this is better for me oh isn't it
just the bishop out thought f takes was
the idea which is what I've been with
Miracle like five with this work but
here I'm white is just a bit more
comfortable didn't see that one coming
and I should have well that's bad and
actually twist through not exactly we're
not exactly ideal
chanfle didn't see you for coming look
not good take that Luke check who takes
Knight takes Queen age too it's not
great not too great at all so if it
takes on therefore I probably have to do
something else like f or something along
these lines I have to play from and then
he's okay hmm ok so yes this g5 thing
maybe I should avoid Oh interesting so
probably have to take
ninety five of nine f5 493 maybe I can
do something oh not sure not sure this
is a good decision or not that will seem
let's see probably it is okay who's
calling you on skype so I was thinking
he is not that quick with attack
attacking my porn and maybe okay
checking him Bishop g7 doesn't lead
anywhere rook t1d 44 would be good Oh
I looked in 1d four book g1e will play
look to these six
now I'm getting to the point i think
getting this you for pot for the better
ending
might be even winning ending if i geti
for he is still suffering from those two
pawns on dark square and I can advance
pretty quickly on the queenside oops
let's not make a mouse slip here I had
Bishop c5 ok it's not a big thing
because I mean this is the bishop on g7
cannot save like
time morning let's here I go go over
there I mean I have time here to try I
can't even also go go enter on the Kings
side if I like I'm not sure that this is
the right right way to do it when i go i
can go up to be four and a five and then
King be seven Bishop c5 that there will
be tamping sorry add some swag motifs
clap 85 King b5 yeah the bishop trade is
a black resides yeah that was quite
surprising how it ultimately ended that
I've got a better ending all of a sudden
yeah so he went nite f4 and I overlooked
g5 I mean g5 looks weird m-cap that's a
completely completely crazy computer
line with the evaluation of 0 which is
which is extremely funny now it gives
blacks a match okay that's crazy again
this happened c3 and a g5 I kept I kept
ignoring this possibility and he could
have done it they played this and I
think he I can really take it right yeah
but there's no tactic cop but I
continuously overlook this idea here and
now whoopsie forgiven by the engine
hmm sure White's position is not very
well coordinated to really something I
mean this is not playing at the moment
but whites whites position is not alone
yes this is probably giving something to
me engine wants to cancel long proposal
yeah for luke t for quickly maybe maybe
this is stronger yeah this is what's
helping me but there was one moment
click here when okay six Luke a sexist
pal no I think I would have played in
three and then okay I ok five he just
actually attacks my porn okay then this
will be probably a draw like here is the
computer line I keep forgetting to press
that I'm sorry about it so yeah it's
probably roughly roughly equal can
always get this end yeah that's that's
equal only here who gauge seven was good
uh-huh yeah okay actually this is the
idea of the of the engine that I would
come up with a king I was thinking here
here also good ok it is also good Bishop
e7 it's a bit better probably than
taking the bishop ending I think is that
is a very clean loss there is Mary M cat
very little hope and ultimately will be
some kind of sucks long situation like
here King up here
seven and now how to play for that suks
phone
it's actually not that easy some luck
here yeah it looks terrible but how am I
actually winning or do I have to
actually switch over to the King side
and play maybe maybe I mean I have a
total this is a complete control so
maybe I actually win with coming over
look at this kind of thing I'm sorry
hear hear this kind of thing that I've
here I'm marching the pawn some
something like that and it splits
probably the way to win it they're
promoting yeah this is probably the way
to win it ok guys thanks for watching